Озирніться навколо! Просто погляньте!
Світ прекрасний! Життя теж прекрасне!
На цих кадрах з 2021 року Владислав Єщенко і його активний відпочинок,
подорожі та побачення з дівчиною.
Після лютого 2022-го вже в лавах ЗСУ
він фільмує дні своєї служби на фронті.
Чоловік відмінно стріляв.
Ці моменти тепер він тримає лише у своїй пам’яті…
Владислав приходить на інтерв’ю з DW під руку коханої,
обережно нащупує стілець, сідає і починає свою історію з того,
що змінило його життя назавжди.
30 уламків у мені, розірване обличчя,
зламана щелепа, роздроблені кістки,
випалені, видавлені очі, обпалені руки.
Владислав отримав травму на фронті, будучи сапером.
Про ризики у цій роботі  чоловік знав ще до того,
як пішов воювати добровольцем у березні 2022-го.
До повномасштабного наступу Росії
він працював у групі гуманітарних демінерів "HALO Trust" -
як волонтер.
Робота суто за правилами безпеки, без будь-якого поспіху,
максимально безпечно. На війні час, мабуть,
важливіший за безпеку, тому що втрачений час
може призвести до непоправних наслідків.
Якщо робота на відкритій місцевості, вас можуть "змалювати",
і в цей час в цю локацію, де ви,
автоматично починає "прилітати".
На спецвилазку втрьох їдемо.
Я як повернуся, відразу відпишуся.
Бережіть себе там!
Після цих слів у серпні 2022 року Владислав
вирушив на розмінування поля поблизу Бахмута.
Того дня рідні та дівчина так і не отримали від нього повідомлення,
що завдання минуло успішно.
Внаслідок підриву одного боєприпасу
здетонували усі ті, які були ізольовані.
Я лише відчув подив від того, що вибух, темрява, дзвін у вухах.
Я розумію: біда!
Єдина фраза, яку я вимовив: "Мені потрібна допомога".
Все. Я відчув, як підбігли, підхопили мене за руки.
Друга фраза, яку я сказав: "Мені дуже холодно".
І я відключився. Все, більше не було нічого.
10 днів коми у дніпровській лікарні.
Потім ще два тижні - мовчання від усіх лікарів
навколо про те, що сталося і чому Владислав нічого не бачить,
відколи отямився. Дізнатися правду боєць наважився сам.
В якийсь момент, коли я поставив запитання,
мене почали прив’язувати. Ну, мені намагалися зав’язати руки.
Мабуть, хотіли сказати. Але я тоді зробив відмашку рукою,
сказав: "Не треба, я все розумію".
Лікарі пішли, так нічого і не сказавши
. Мене почали виводити на прогулянку.
Я підійшов, точніше я з батьком йшов, прогулювався,
перші кроки свої робив. І ми тоді наодинці були.
Я кажу: "Тату, ми домовлялися ніколи в житті
не брехати одне одному, що б не сталося.
Давай чесно: що з очима?"
Секундна пауза, і він каже:
"У тебе їх нема, тобі їх видалили".
Вердикт лікарів: жодного шансу на зір.
Численні контузії і падіння слуху до 10 відсотків.
Владислав почав реабілітацію і знайомство з життям
у суцільній темряві. Коштом благодійників,
які відгукнулися на прохання допомогти, йому вдалося сплатити
встановлення імплантів в очі, а також слуховий апарат.
Він навчився сам готувати і користуватися смартфоном.
А сьогодні за руку з коханою Валерією впевнено йде вулицею.
Коли в мене паличка з’явилася, ми ходили ось так само за руку.
І Лєра допомагала мені, якщо треба було повертати кудись,
вона повертала рукою.
Зараз пара разом із нами підійшла до особливого для них місця -  РАЦСу,
де місяць тому вони офіційно стали чоловіком і дружиною.
Я просто любляча дружина, яка підтримує його в усіх починаннях,
в усіх успіхах, у всіх поразках і дає мотивацію рухатися далі.
У нас на обручках вигравіювана фраза "Одне ціле".
Вона зараз мої очі і руки. Ми просто одне ціле,
робимо одне і те ж із однаковими помислами.
Цього літа Владислав та Валерія зважилися на ще один спільний крок
: разом заснувати благодійний фонд допомоги ветеранам,
що отримали тяжкі поранення на фронті - "Побачимо перемогу".
Його мета - не лише оплачувати лікування бійцям,
а і допомагати їм з контактами фахових спеціалістів
та адаптацією до нового життя. Для цього пара
вже підписала кілька меморандумів про співпрацю
з реабілітаційними центрами в Україні.
Моя благодійна організація буде змінювати
найбільшу несправедливість: людина, яка потрапляє в біду,
їй треба шукати інформацію і шукати допомогу.
Я хочу стати організацією, яка буде шукати людину,
щоб дати їй інформацію і надати допомогу.
Щоб для людини, яка потрапила в біду,
я був першим, який, знаєте: "Я поруч! Я вже допомагаю!"
Зараз пара прямує до бійця, який, так само як і Владислав,
пережив втрату зору, а ще - ампутацію половини руки
після поранення на фронті у березні 2022-го.
Владислав і Валерія одразу вирішили допомогти йому.
Бажаю здоров’я!
- Я знаю, у тебе з кінцівкою проблема.
- Так, у мене ось.
- А ти з кимось щодо цього консультувався?
- Ще ні…
- Ось це одна з моїх пропозицій для тебе.
Я розповім тобі про моїх партнерів. Я впевнений, вони зможуть допомогти.
Присідай, Владиславе!
- Дякую! Сідай ліворуч, бо в мене ліве вухо тільки чує.
Я можу переговорити, надіслати твої документи, і якщо ти готовий,
тебе зможуть прийняти у Львівському реабілітаційному центрі.
Олексій півтора року тому лишився з травмою сам на сам.
Дружина забрала чотирьох дітей і покинула його.
Коштів на лікування в нього не лишилося.
Але три тижні тому його зір на одному оці
врятували завдяки допомозі фонду Владислава.
Той оплатив операцію зі встановлення бійцю нової рогівки.
Пройшло три тижні, як мені зробили операцію,
пішов четвертий тиждень: я бачу результат і дякую Богові!
Дякую Богові, що він відкрив твоє серце, Владиславе!
Я розумію його дуже!
Тому що сам я півтора року не бачив, це темрява така!
Цифри побачив, літери! Я так зрадів!
Це справді дорогого вартує! У мене у самого емоції!
Мрія Владислава зараз - допомагати таким бійцям,
як Олексій, також і лікуванням закордоном.
А ще взяти участь у реформуванні системи реабілітації
ветеранів у майбутньому. Для цього, він певний, у нього є все:
підтримка коханої, віра в себе та бачення перемоги України
у війні з Росією.
Я і зараз кажу: "Дайте мені одне робоче око,
і я повернуся назад до своїх хлопців, я готовий на 100 відсотків!"
Але ні, на жаль, цього не буде, тому,
коли мені сказали про те, що все, очей не буде,
я зрозумів, що треба життєві сили та енергію віддавати на щось інше.
Бути непотрібним і просто існувати я не буду!
Я буду корисним і буду жити!